it might not feel like it today but
spring is here and our celebrity
lifestyle expert sema cohen is joining
us today
to share the absolute must-haves and
essentials for the spring season check
it out
hello las vegas now and happy spring
winter is behind us and spring is here
i'm excited to share with you my
favorite spring essentials and
must-haves
for the whole family first up we have
perfect image perfect image brings the
spy experience to your home
by providing safe affordable
professional strength peel products
perfect image gives you the power tools
and professional assistance
to guide you on your journey to a
healthier
more confident you no matter your skin
health concern
from aging wrinkles or spots to uneven
tone
or breakouts perfect image can help you
find the right product for your unique
skin
needs and goals i love this company
great great product
find them at perfectimage.com
here we have health health aims to
create clean and effective nutrition
and personal care products that are
artificially free
organic and made in the u.s
their daily vitamin is the most complete
lineup
of 29 foods and vegetables in a
multivitamin
no gmo it's vegan and it has no
synthetic fillers
health pre-workout is a natural energy
supplement
great to take before you workout or
before a busy day ahead
it is made with real strawberry lemonade
and again
no artificial flavors or fake
ingredients
a clean and safe option for yourself
your kids and even teenagers you can
find them at
healthbrands.co
print fresh print fresh is a collection
of sleepwear
stationery and gift items in unique
whimsical prints that are hand screened
printed
made from 100 organic cotton
print fresh offers a variety of styles
including
long sets short sets and ropes in all
sizes up to six eggs they partner with
socially and environmentally conscious
vendors in india
who do beautiful hand-created work
find them at printfresh.com for
all your health nuts out there i got you
covered sushi sushi is an organic cold
pressed
nut gem or juice company that's based in
san diego
california they carry a wide variety of
juices
wellness shots kombuchas and now the new
addition
of sparkling juices their sparkling cold
pressed juice
is full of antioxidants vitamin c
organic fruit
and even herb blends it has no added
flavors
no preservatives or sweeteners you can
find them at your local target
or any of your local retailers you can
also receive a monthly subscription of
suzha
when you subscribe online through
souzajuice.com
thank you sima las vegas now